你以为你在努力学习器呢
其实你不过是在提升你打工的能力
我们很能对这个理解都是错的
如果你继续照的这个方向走
你未来几年和现在不会有太大的改变的
我给大家怀疼地图
然后明确告诉你你是卡在哪儿的
你应该怎么做具体应该做什么
来吧 这样回到我们的现实生活中来
你有没有遇到过这样一种情况
明明这个人能力不如你
但是人家正前就病毒
要家也病毒 用户也病毒
而且好像也不是很情况
对吧 你以为这个就是运气
就说命 是吧
我告诉你不是是人家安装了你身上没有安装的东西
到底是什么呢
思想
这思想是有顺着的
还是有讲着的 首先我们说第一下叫他记得
我们很绝对记得的理解都是错的
我我久了一次啊 比如说你去应骗
然后呢 记得你哪儿你写的是
我会做PBT 你的心虑会很低
甚至你连工作都找不到
但是我你记得那一篇你写的是
我上一份工作是为雷军做PBT
会有很绝想着要你
甚至你的这个心受也会很高
我们很多人对记得的理解就是我要掌握
这个我也会我也会我要学很多的东西
我告诉你 记能不是你会什么
不是你能做什么 记能是你能带来什么样的结果
不是为言从天AI来了以后
你能做那个事很容易被AI替代
AI替代不了的事通过那个记能产生什么结果
第二个什么呢 第二个叫非责
你他两个完全竞成相同的人
那他是怎么获得用过呢 一种啊 一种
就是我我通过主关系啊
平时一些联系啊 没事可能会有些硬抽啊
我朋友都关系多
还有一种的话呢
就是我会把我自己的一些做事的成功的今天啊
失败的坑啊
然后我通过保守分享出来
一旦出现经济下星
你会发现强硬种 通过关系的
你的幼料会断压实的想法
因为别人的观别人的生意也不太好
但是通过网络的可能会好很多
我不想说太多各位 今天是网络时代
网络时代
那么我之前发了个那说 标得应差
什么标得应差
标得应怕每个把你知道的经验
真成的成功经验失败的坑真成的分享给人
我发现很多人还是还是那个死闹型
就有时候给他分享一些我自己赚钱的一些方法
想法还是留言
你想一想吧 真正赚钱的人会把东西分享给你吗
兄弟信息是打
信息真的那么值钱吗
好像我分享给你就理解了
你就明白了 你就会做一样
我告诉你信息是不值钱的
真正值钱的是你对这件事情的深度理解和值行能力
好 让我们说第三件事
我好像
我也我的能力也可以啊 你知道钱了 对不对
然后呢 我也分发我了
我又用乎了 对不对
但是我发现要我太忙了
是不是
然后你会发现你原来是给一个老板打工
这现在给一对老板打工而已
但是呢
你时间非常忙
这个时候你要干嘛
这个时候你需要资产
什么叫资产
资产就是在你不需要重复投入金的情况
你仍然可以转到钱
我给大家去过小类子
比如说去年的时候我们有老火箭
跟我说
我都过来跟我们分享一下
怎么做自媒体吧
七年七八月份吧
我们自己的像活动是别配的
就是我们不是没有可成贵的
但是呢
就是来了以后我们可能不要做会上啊
对不对
可能有些道具啊 对吧
我们要答应你得拆病非那是你的事情 对吧
我看
还有人说我
花了三千块钱 参加 胡子哥的线 胡子哥的线 胡子哥 大哥
那是你的住宿费
那是你的拆病非那是你的活动
那是你的跟那个火车道的费
我是不少你简单的
好吧
但是呢
当然是我把我自己
就是分享的那个那种
就是我是怎么做自媒体的
一些方法一些心得
考了我的光到网上了
我给他演世界怎么做
那小钱怎么做自产
放上去了
现在差不多有六千块
我基本上从来都不选择吧
但是有六千块大家可以算一下
有多少钱吧 对吧
所以什么的自产
第一个就是你不需要重复投入劳动
但是你可以获取收益的
第二个是很重要
就是你具有了意价的能力
对吧
你你你会发现你不需要工作的时候
仍然会有收益的时候
你这一家全都不一样了
有的时候我直播的时候人说
回头来
讲一下你的小报通过
对不起不讲
不讲 我不推荐你们借
我是去哥哥会想
我靠这么就逼吗
他更好奇呢
对
但是哥哥们你睡一下
如果没有收益
这是我唯一的收益了
那时候
你会不会怎么办
大哥我给你多讲一下
你别糟了
这时候这时候我们说的
第三个部分
第四个你要安装的能力
叫自动化
自动化放着最后不是说
他不重要
但自动化什么
自动化是放大气
就你显然做到好
他把那个好给你放大
显然做得差
他把那个差给你放大
显然那三项
你没有你放大什么呢
对不对
你比如说我写个文章
都没人看
我有一个什么气能都没人用了
然后也没啥用户
你自动化啥呢
你都不空软嘛
对不对
所以各位
就是我们很多人卡在什么地方
就是认为我要努力的提升体能
但实际上他说是四项
你远的四项各位
你尝射自己打个分
四项的四项呢
气能分发自材
还有自动化
然后从那个分到十分
那个自己打个分
我敢保证大部分的分是这样的
气能分
七分过八分
分发一分到两分
自材
那个分
自动化
所以你能提回到我前面说这个话吗
你努力学习性能
其实你不过是在提升你的打工的能力而已
所以你要做的事情是什么呢
你要做的事情把这个分
列出来
列完那个分别大份
那个分低化时间重点去通机那个
让这个系统运转起来
那么我必须提醒一下
那个技能五分是这个分
五分是这个分
六分才是一分
所以如果你赚不到钱努力提升你的气能
如果你的赚到钱了
但是赚得不多分发
如果你这个有了
也赚到钱了
对吧
但是你的时间这个受限了
怎么办
你要把他走上自材
自材
叫能力产命化
对不对
如果钱们都都有了
你要完成
自动化
所以我们真正要提升的不是技能
而是一样完整的地图